alander boton's got this quote where he
says loneliness is a kind of tax we have
to pay to atone for a certain complexity
of mind there's two things we don't want
to be not enough and different it's what
a therapist said to me recently she goes
I'm a therapist for billionaire seos and
royalty she goes the two things that
people struggle with fundamentally are
feeling different we don't want to feel
different that's a rejection from one's
tribe which used to mean back in the day
through a process of self-preservation
we'd die earlier we'd get more ill our
immune systems would break down and the
second one is not feeling like you're
enough which means you're not valuable
to the tribe so not being part of the
tribe or of good use to the tribe causes
a bunch of signals in our body which
then manifest as physiological disease
and psychological disease and it's cool
sometimes I think when I'm feeling in
that such a way maybe I'm feeling lonely
or I'm feeling really different or some
I've got some feedback which makes me
feel like I'm Different in a fundamental
way I just ground myself in the
understanding that even the fact that I
feel that makes me like everybody else
and in terms of loneliness I've had to
kind of carve out my own new tribe in my
life